where was i a year ago today
or where was i a year ago this month
because i maybe can't find an entry that
was exactly today but i love
sort of seeing how far i've come and
also seeing like
remember when you were worried about
that like that thing that you were so
worried about that never came to pass
but you spent
you know untold energy like trying to
figure it out and now it doesn't even
matter
um i think is really powerful all
especially in this year where you know
back in january i'm like 20 20.
it's our golden year like all the things
and
now it's just like oh girl you you have
no idea
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that
happen i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is the adorable
vulnerable funny wonderful
human being rachel hollis uh we had
i mean we had a giant conversation about
life it was
you know everything from relationships
to the relationship
with ourself um the lessons that we've
learned
the things that we are going to take
moving forward
childhood inner child and we also then
at the end of it sort of created what
the future
world looks like i hope that you can
take a lot from this interview
and i hope you uh you know can
learn just you know some different
different ways of thinking and
answer the call to wake up answer the
call to
look in the mirror and to hold yourself
accountable and create the life that
you really want how are you i'm good how
are you doing
i'm good but that's just like a throw
that's that's a throwaway answer let's
answer how like we're really doing
i am tired
it's been a really long day i start
production on the show tomorrow
and so this was the day i don't know if
your team ever does this with you where
there it's back at from you know eight
until now it's just completely stacked
and it's sort of like we gotta fit all
these things
into all these little boxes to get
everything done so that then you can go
into production tomorrow
um so i'm tired and i
am also debating with myself about
whether or not
i am really gonna cook dinner for my
children
or if we are going to have takeout that
is literally
like as i was logging on to the zoom i
was like can you
cook dinner tonight or are we gonna get
chick-fil-a i don't know we're gonna
find out yeah that's how i
am how about you um well
first off i think that if you can um
there's like little things i have for
myself like if money can solve a problem
let it you know things like that like
getting a cleaning lady instead of
having to do that myself or like
you know if um if getting going to get
dinner or ordering dinner makes your
life easier then you know what some days
you need that so
right um how am i i'm um
[Music]
i'm feeling really
like a lot is coming through it's just
like a lot of downloads a lot of
information
more and more clarity um waves of
emotion still
like you know of all the events that
have happened in my life and
you know some of that comes and goes um
but
generally feeling kind of just a lot of
information coming through especially
recently
um and the one good feeling is i'm just
like
really and i posted this on social media
i'm falling in love with this mystery
of life like think about how
it's like i was thinking to myself it's
like surprises so life
life is generally kind of like surprises
and not all surprises are good sometimes
you open up your gift at
you know for your birthday or christmas
or whatever you whatever you would open
up a gift for and you open it and you're
like
oh it sucks you know
and sometimes it's not a good surprise
and then other times
it's really really good and so um
but life is kind of just a bunch of
endless surprises really
and we think we have it all under
control and we think we've got it
figured out but
um but uh it's gonna continue to
surprise us and
i'm just kind of learning to really love
that it keeps it how do you process like
when you're in a
in a season or in an experience of like
a lot of information is coming at you
what are the things that you do to
process the information you're receiving
uh i journal me too yeah
i talk to my girlfriends i'm
big on talking yes um i would imagine
that probably falls under your umbrella
too
um are you a verbal processor
does it help you to sort of talk through
yeah i'm not only a verbal processor
but it is part of it can help more and
more come through
um i
yeah i think those are the two biggest
things
do you do any journal every day like
consistently are you sort of like when
you're feeling
what you're feeling then you're like i
got to get this down yeah i'm not a
religious
sort of person about i use religion and
i'm
only meaning it for being a a a timeline
of
of um repetition um i'm not religious
about journaling
um yeah it's just kind of as needed
it's extremely therapeutic for me so i
but i
i can kind of process with my eyes
closed process what i write process when
i talk
process when i you know look at the sun
rising so
yeah what about you i so so i do
i have a gratitude practice that i do
every day um so i write down things that
i'm grateful for every morning
and then most of the time if i'm
journaling it's because i'm feeling
something that i need to work through
or i do i would say
98 of the time and this was like a
previous life
but if i was on an airplane i always
journal on airplanes
because i feel like there's some great
thing that happens with
you know there's like the ambient noise
and if you don't buy the internet then
nobody can access you and you're just
sort of alone with your thoughts
and usually i feel like i'm going or
coming from something big and so you
know either i'm going to a big work
event or maybe i'm on my way to vacation
and so i'm setting my intentions for
what i want to
be able to you know have out of that
experience so
i actually love it because i i carry a
notebook with me everywhere
and in my notebook for years it will
have like
atx to lax or
you know um jfk to you know
i don't know like but i love remembering
like what airport i was going
from and to because i also think that
that sort of
colors what's you know if you're flying
out of jfk versus
honolulu those are two completely
different energies that you're bringing
to that process
does it take you back into the feeling
as well because there's a visualization
that you can have for it too
you you like can visualize yourself
yeah and i i i review a lot of the
things that i journal so it's one of you
know i
i love in fact i do this i've done this
a lot especially this year
of like where was i a year ago
today or where was i a year ago this
month because i
maybe can't find an entry that was
exactly today but i love
sort of seeing how far i've come and
also seeing like
remember when you were worried about
that like that thing that you were so
worried about that never came to pass
but you spent
you know untold energy like trying to
figure it out and now it doesn't even
matter
um i think is really powerful all
especially in this year
where you know back in january i'm like
20 20.
it's our golden year like all the things
and
now it's just like oh girl you you have
no idea
yeah strap in um i
i what would you have told yourself if
you were to go back and
knowing what you know now what would you
have told yourself uh
new year's eve going into 2020.
you know what's really interesting is
that when i go back i do a lot of stuff
every year at the end of the year
and the start of the year i do it by
myself and i do it with my friends we're
really big on
getting together setting intentions goal
settings we do it
all the time and it's just an excuse to
like drink and
have a cheese board and like cast your
future or whatever
um right
um but
i feel like i know this sounds so
weird but i feel like i knew change was
coming
in some way because when i go back and i
review all of my notes or
here's what i think of the future or
here as i'm laying these things out
it was a really weird time at the end of
last year that i couldn't
i i couldn't like grasp
what to write down i couldn't see sort
of
specificity i couldn't like in a way
that's very unlike me i remember
i did um i was with some of my closest
friends and we
always do like brunch into some kind of
vision cast dream cast whatever and so
we're having brunch and then we did this
whole thing we all asked the same
questions and
we journaled then we went around and
everybody had to share so you can like
hold each other accountable and
i couldn't answer so many of the
questions like oh what do you need to
release what do you need to take what
and i
in hindsight feel like
my gut was sort of telling me like
things are in flux or things are going
to change or you can't
see what it's going to be because it's
so
it's about to take such a drastic turn
that you like i just
i know that sound it doesn't sound weird
to you because i know you're
you vibe on this with me but um i feel
like
i my intuition sort of knew life was
about to change
[Music]
would you would you have told yourself
anything would it have helped like
you know because there's that thought
too where it's like you kind of need to
be
i know for myself like to learn the
lessons that i've learned like i
i i had to get dropped in the middle of
the ocean
no island in sight you know um to really
bring me there because i think we're
very similar in a way we both
like push and get things done you make
things happen
and um strong strong-minded
strong-willed
sometimes you gotta let go sometimes
yeah
sometimes you gotta get [ __ ] i don't
think that i would
and i think this about my whole life is
that i wouldn't
want to know and i truly wouldn't want
to do things differently because i
really do to the like marrow of my being
believe that it it happens as it
was supposed to it happens as it was
meant to it happens in the time it was
meant to happen
like i really do believe that and i
think that if
we had you know if we could time travel
or if someone could tell us that
something was coming
it would change what was meant to be and
the way that it was meant to be and so i
really wouldn't um
[Music]
no i mean i think i think i would just
tell myself like
it's gonna be okay but then even in that
i wouldn't need to hear that because i
live my life thinking like it's
gonna be okay it might not be great
today
but i believe that it can be great again
someday and then
for right now we're just going to keep
moving forward but um
i just had too many experiences in my
life where
in it it was the hardest
season the hardest year the hardest time
and then
i can look back five years later and go
oh my god but look
what it gave me um so i have a tattoo on
my wrist
that says embrace the suck
because every good
thing in my life came on the other side
of something really hard
you know um my three children you know
came on the other side of
you know pregnancy and labor right and
my daughter who's the baby that was
five years in the adoption process to
get her that was
awful it was so terrible and
i have noah because of that like so many
really hard things produce really
beautiful things so
um yeah i don't think that why is that
because i 100
agree i mean there is oh i i actually
tell people i'm like
if you haven't been buckled over like in
convulsions crying
world upside down feeling helpless
feeling
just devastated like if there's not
if you haven't gotten there then
you haven't really gotten to the part
where change really happened so why
why does that why do you think that it
is because we're both agreeing here
you've got to go through the pain to get
growth there's always
it's growing pains right right right
well i think i think everybody
is going to go through something painful
everybody every human being the
difference
is that there are people who go through
something painful and it changes them
for the better
and then there are people who go through
something painful and they look
for the goodness they look for not like
oh this was meant to happen but is there
something
is there wisdom in this for me is there
a lesson what am i meant to learn who
was
you know what what came out of this
experience um
that we'll all go through hard things
it's just that you know you could talk
to another person who'd be like yep
the universe is out to get me you know
the
this political party that boss this
thing like
they choose to see the world or or maybe
so many hard things have happened to
them that they don't even know how to
get out from
under the weight of all of the hard
things that they've been through and so
they can only see the world through the
lens
of awful and
i'm just so inspired and have been so
inspired by people who have lived
through
really hard things and managed to find
beauty and manage to rebuild and manage
to become
something um and i think i had an
example of that
from my like my whole life my um
my paternal grandparents who i was very
close to
and still feel them with me they've gone
to heaven long time but i
they're always with me um
were farm hands you know
were picked cotton picked potatoes
you know my grandma had six kids and
they had no money and they
had no real education and they
just kept showing up for life
and kept working hard and kept looking
for the good and like
from the very earliest memories i have
of my grandma
i have that example of you know
someone who just kept showing up with
optimism and with hope
and with belief in her family and in
humans
and um you know and
and enjoyed good food and
growing her roses and my grandpa
and so i just i always had this example
of someone who
i mean her life had was so hard
and she just kept looking for goodness
would
i i wanted to ask you because i think
that something that's
that's special about you is that
um look you're like you're helping so
many people and you're giving them
strength and giving them sort of tools
and
tricks and tips to how to do things deal
with things get through
things and so there's a there's a
strength there
um and so it doesn't mean though
that life isn't hard super hard
so what i wanted to ask about and you
just started sort of
giving me some examples with your
grandma
but it's your you have a good
relationship
it's your relationship with discomfort
it doesn't mean you don't have it but
you just have a good relationship
with discomfort i'm gonna
stand up and dust myself off and i'm
gonna choose
optimism and life is a bucket of [ __ ]
right now but you know what it's not
gonna stay like that
and i'm going to do these things like i
think it can be off-putting
at times for people because they're like
oh whatever you just
everything's just you know don't you
ever just break down and
you know tell me that show me the
vulnerability but i i just think that
you know my senses is your relationship
with discomfort is something that
is is something you've cultivated well
my whole childhood was discomfort
my whole childhood was um
i shouldn't i guess i shouldn't say
whole because there were
beautiful parts of it you know i have um
like i said my relationship with my
grandparents i have
really beautiful memories of my
childhood but um
i i truly believe that my parents did
the best that they could
with what they had but their best
was not great and um
my i grew up inside of chaos i grew up
inside of fear i grew up
um daddy had a awful temper
and you never knew you know what was
gonna happen you never knew
are we gonna have a nice family dinner
or um
is he gonna get angry and they're gonna
get in a fight he's gonna punch a hole
in the wall
or through you know rip the tv and throw
it back like you just
you never knew and so um
i lived i can i've done a lot of therapy
to understand sort of the effect that
that has on
a child and growing up in this
anxiety of a i don't
i never feel safe so like as a child i
never feel safe because i never know
what to expect
and also um my role then was
to keep the peace like try and make
everybody happy
try and uh you know oh no no like let's
make it a joke let's
you know we'll just laugh this off it's
fine like oh she didn't mean that like
he
you know so there's a lot of stuff um
from the time i was little that
you know i've written a lot about it in
my books and
there is a whole bucket of [ __ ]
that i will never write about because
it's
too awful but when i say
that i am optimistic and when i say that
i keep
choosing joy even when it's hard and
when i say that
like i can see how things are for me
i hope that people at this point at
least the people who read my books
understand that i'm not just talking out
of one side of my mouth i'm not
it's it's very easy to look at my life
now
and sort of you know um be flippant
about like oh well
easy for you to say you're a successful
author or
like i understand that i will never
truly understand
the full privilege of being a white
woman
of having the access that i have of now
getting to a place where i have
financial resources that i didn't have
but what
people can understand or not is that i
grew up poor
i grew up in a shitty
hard home life
i moved away from home at 17 like moved
to a different city at 17 like wasn't
even old enough to
lease my own apartment because i just
wanted to escape i wanted to get away
and i remember when for
for all of high school that i just kept
thinking
like i'm going to get out of here i'm
going to get out of here i'm going to
get is all i thought about was all i
focus on it's probably the original
like me goal setting is like going back
to those teenage years
and it was all i thought about was just
getting away from this house i just
wanted to be out of this house i wanted
to be out of this environment because i
kept telling myself
if you leave this place and you're still
unhappy
then you will know that it's you it's
not your environment
it's not these people you will for the
rest of your life have to take
responsibility for the fact that it's
you
and i remember that as a teenager saying
like
right now i'm in this environment and i
think that that's why life is so
can i cuss on the show i've already come
once okay
right now like i think that their why
life is so shitty
but if i get out of here and i'm still
miserable then i will know that it was
just geography
it didn't it doesn't matter if i have a
bad attitude if i'm negative
if i'm the if i'm this way then it won't
matter where i move
and it won't matter how much money i
make and it won't matter who i know or
who my friends are i will always be this
way
and so in in that awareness
i i remember moving to la and working
three jobs and
just all i want to do is survive just
live in this little crappy apartment and
survive
away from that home life and i would
have days where it would like oh my gosh
you know i would be overwhelmed or it
would be hard and i'll be like nope
nope remember where you come from
and remember what it felt like and at
least
this might be this crappy apartment in
hollywood and you might
only be able to shop at the 99 cent
store but you own this life
nobody gets to come into your space
nobody gets to yell at you nobody gets
to make you feel less than like you get
to own this
and a a hard existence that you choose
for yourself
beats anything that's
that someone else forces on you because
at least
from my perspective at least then you're
in control
[Music]
so i'm gonna assume that you weren't
miserable when you left
no and there were certainly
circumstances
that would have made me feel anxious
or scared or nervous or any sort of
suffering um
but i think that's truly that first year
probably
of being in la was when i really you
know
i don't even know that people are using
the term mindset
20 years ago but i really did learn to
control my mindset
starting then because i just kept
thinking
no i don't want to be like them i don't
want to be like that
and i have to be able to control the way
i think
about the world that i find myself in or
i will be miserable forever
that's incredibly rare i mean i'm 38 and
i'm like
learning some of these things and you
know in recent years but to
have that kind of awareness
self-awareness knowing that you were
responsible for your own happiness to me
that's
maybe that's is your gift your gift was
to have enough self-awareness to be able
to tell people to have some damn
self-awareness
maybe i mean i think that i also
you know i i went through this
catastrophic life event when i was 14.
my older brother committed suicide and
it
whatever our family was before that
moment
that event annihilated
whatever it was into something so much
worse
and i really do think
at 14 was when i started to
kind of i don't know how to like look at
my life
from i don't know if it was sort of the
out of body experience of having gone
through that trauma
but i really did start to take a step
back and go
man this is not okay that's not okay
and this shouldn't be you know just sort
of in the way that our family handled
things or did things
and what's so interesting is that i've
been doing a lot of work this year
on inner child like working with
energy healer therapists the whole thing
like inner child who are you
you at different ages all the stuff i
know you're here for it
and absolutely going to make you go and
want you to go into that
so it's so powerful but in doing this
work i had the idea a couple of weekends
ago was like
i'm going to go find my old journals
because i have this huge like tupperware
thing of like childhood
memories i've got you know diaries from
elementary school
journals like all this stuff and so i
went and read through
my diaries and my journals and i think
it's i
a it was the first time that i was
conscious
of as a very little girl like so
elementary school
that even then i was writing things or
processing things
that even my seven-year-old brain or my
eight-year-old brain knew
was not okay knew that the way that my
parents were behaving or the things that
they were doing were not okay
which is wild because
i have an eight-year-old right like i
have
it's so interesting to think of your own
kids or if you have kids in your life
that you're like
i was ford's age and i was writing this
diary entry that is beyond
[ __ ] up and so a it made me aware of
like man
even from a real like much earlier than
i realized
that i knew that the way that we
operated as a family was not okay
and then in the journal after my brother
died
is when i consciously was like
i'm getting out of here like i and i was
14 so i was only a freshman in high
school but i was like i
i've got to leave that like i it became
you know it's like in the diary it's
like oh i like this boy i like that
that's all
apparently i thought about as a little
girl and then that moment was like
okay how much money do i have saved how
am i going to do this
what's the job i'm going to get
everything from 14
until i left home at 17 was about how to
get out
i feel like
you that event woke you up
and put your put your family to sleep
like because that's right because we go
in or we go out
right so right we i think i heard you
say in one of your videos like it's
nothing's been there's never been a
sexier time to numb out
right well i mean people are doing that
and then yeah but it's also like great
call to your own truth and
and learning the lessons right now which
is the road that i've gone down
i'm sensing it's the road you've got you
go down you've been going down that road
since you were 14.
and so how crazy that that happens and
i just sense that it woke you up would
you agree with that
yeah know that and i think that's a
great way to think about it and i
haven't thought it
thought of it in those terms before but
a hundred percent
um because it was just sort of this jolt
of
and maybe it was that whatever
like sort of facade or like you know the
house built on sand or whatever
that ryan died and then it was just gone
and there was nothing and we were
starting from
scratch and i you know i had never told
this story but in the new book i
i tell the story of the day my brother
died is the last day
my parents ever parented me and i was
14.
and that and i mean
legitimately they checked out and
from 14 until i graduated like nobody
one time
you know did you brush your teeth did
you do your homework what are your
grades
never how um no and
and what i say in the book is i've had
more conversations
with my 11 year old about fortnite
than either one of my parents have ever
had with me about
my brother's death you know what i saw
that day
what i went through the trauma of that
experience nothing
and it
is wild but here's the thing
i and i don't know how this will be
received but i'm just going to speak
truthfully to your listeners i would not
be the woman that i am i wouldn't be who
i am
if i hadn't gone through that experience
um
and knowing that this chapter i had
written this chapter and i knew
that it would hurt i knew it would hurt
my mom
to read it and i wanted to tell her
in advance that i hey this is what's in
this book and i you know and i didn't
know how that would be received and
um but i wanted to give her a heads up
because that's a really harsh thing to
have
in print you know widely out in the
world and have your friends sort of come
to you and be like hey
um and so i told her it was coming and
she sent me a note
at the end of last week because she had
read the book and she when
when i told her she surprised me by
saying
um she's like i hate that that's the
truth
but that's the truth like i i really
hate
that that happened i i hate but
i'm not gonna argue with you because
that is
you know and look i give so much
um honor to the fact that
i have no idea what it would feel like
to lose your only son in that way i have
no idea
so and and that was you know she was
just like i i wish
i you know if i could i'd give anything
to like have done that better or go back
and i was like mom
honestly you they didn't
they didn't grow up in homes or family
they didn't have the resources they
didn't have the information they didn't
they wouldn't even have known how they
coped with what they knew and
it is what it is how did that feel
though for her to say i'm sorry and for
her to
receive that shocking for me
because i have known that i needed to
have that conversation for
six months and i didn't
you know did not six months or like your
whole life
that went specifically six months
because i just
knew that that this that thing was going
to come up
because i tell you that's just the book
the book but that's just the book
but that's also not to be honest i
won't if i
i mean this feels like we're having a
therapy session and this feels like way
too
deep if i tried to dig in
and unpack all of the stuff with my
parents
i could not have a relationship with my
parents
that's real wow because
then there would need to be some
accountability
and that accountability would mean that
we have no relationship at all
and so i choose to
have a relationship it's not close
i'm not close with either parent but i
have a relationship and i love them
and they love their grandkids and that
feels
good enough that's a lot that's heavy
um thank you for sharing that um yeah
what i hear
like what comes to mind is the first
thing i thought was
forgiveness like so you know where is
there
room is there room is there even a
crack in this wall that they've built
that you've built to get like the as a
systematically in your life
is there a crack in there where you can
even feel how there could be forgiveness
to be able to have a relationship if you
really were to unpack it all
i you know i i you know
i read so much on this i this idea of
like
if you can't forgive someone then
is it like you're drinking poison and
you're you know for the rest of your
life and
um
i'm trying to think of how
it doesn't feel and i and i have said
this to her
my god if someone listening to this
knows either my parents
like be a bro and do not send them this
podcast episode
um but
i don't know if other children who maybe
have grown up in similar circumstances
can understand this thought
but it doesn't feel
safe to
if to forgive to me would be to let
guards down
like to just be like kind of open of
like oh right we've forgotten this thing
are we forgiven we've forgotten we're
like moving forward
and if that if it was truly that
idea that does not feel
um it doesn't feel safe
because i don't i don't trust
that it i wouldn't get hurt again
and so for me it's a boundary of
we're going to have a relationship from
here but i'm not willing
like to unpack and to really dig in and
to like
go to therapy together and like do it
whatever
that would maybe produce a um maybe that
would produce a closer relationship
um but that's not something that feels
i don't know you know i don't know the
rest of my life but that definitely
right now
just feels like surprises
life is a bunch of surprises well right
now well like forget about them forget
about that dynamic i think this is
this is a powerful concept that like
kind of brings
emotion to me even just sort of thinking
about this from my own perspective
um but it's it's really big
um so what have you what have you
learned to forgive yourself for
i think um i guess i don't think in
terms of
forgiving myself i think that i have
learned over time i'm very graceful with
myself
and if i could have a wish or a hope for
other people
it would be striving for a similar level
of grace
of accepting myself as i am
even as i work to become something new
and different and evolve
and i think that the grace that i have
with myself
comes like having this level of grace
then
um definitely eroded
some of that unrelenting drive
that i had you know 10 years ago and
maybe meant that i produced more and
then i produced at a higher level and
that i was
more ambitious and all of these things
but also came at
an incredible expense on my health
my relationship with my my kids my
relationship
with my partner um
i think that i have learned over time to
really just
be like okay you know maybe today we're
gonna kill it
right and we're just gonna be the
greatest leader and the greatest mom and
we you know made dinner we did the thing
and maybe tomorrow
the only thing that you can do is you
know
get chick-fil-a and you know watch a
movie and wear sweatpants
and both sides of you are awesome
and maybe the um the person who needed
to kind of hibernate and have a moment
to kind of recoup
is what makes it possible for you to go
be
the badass tomorrow so i guess i don't
think in terms of forgiveness
i think i'm very accepting of myself
and i don't know that i was a decade ago
that's probably been helpful
what have you seen like again because of
course we had
wha what was supposed to be i think 15
minute conversation
an hour 15 yeah so
like obviously i remember a lot of the
stuff that we talked about and of course
this whole inner child and that stuff
like you're both diving down this rabbit
hole
like you know it just keeps going
um so what have you found has been
what's your most
recent what is the what is your most
recent
situation where you can see
the inner child the the way that your
childhood went
the things that you learned how to do to
cope and survive then
that isn't serving you now what needs to
die
what needs um transformed
one of the big things that i'm working
on and have been working on
for you know 10 years maybe
is anxiety and
i had this epiphany about anxiety did i
talk to you about this when we were
yeah we were about that yeah um so
i have you know five six years ago
really started to
um i was having debilitating anxiety
attacks and it was
truly ruling my life and
i started going to therapy i started
reading books i did all these things to
kind of learn how to deal with the
anxiety which
truly was what started me on this
personal development journey
um but i did all these things and
what i think is so fascinating about
anytime in our lives where we're
working on ourselves is that it's just
this onion
and you never run out of layers like you
think you've like figured out all the
things about this topic and then you're
like
like my best friend sami always says
like oh i just made another connection
like i just connected again
why that thing triggered this thing
which is so powerful
yes right another day like a really big
thing and i'm like
like oh my god i mean listen to i was
like oh my god
that like [ __ ] voice that i like tells
me mean things when i get a little
insecure
something happens i'm like you know both
of our parents probably shouldn't
i'm like that's my dad it's me yeah
those are the things yeah
that's not me i ask actually often i ask
women
the voice that's in the back your head
the one that says mean things i i
usually ask is it a man or a woman
which is always really interesting
because depending on
how you're raised or who you interacted
with or whatever it's different
and then the second question is do you
know the voice
because to have that epiphany of like oh
it's dad
that's you know which even in that
there's some like
well i will be damned if you are still
controlling me you know at 38 years old
if you're i'm still that's so powerful
though
if we can understand why we do things
why we are triggered why we're putting i
i honestly believe if we can understand
why we can figure out anyhow
but you have to understand why it's
happening in the first place and so many
people will not
dive in to to that um so for me
this anxiety is something i've been i've
been working through and dealing with
and
i have so like
i'm like i got this right and not to say
that i still
don't get anxiety but it's not at all
what it used to be once upon a time
and then i recently had this epiphany
of uh you know i've been working with a
therapist and we've been talking about
me at different ages of my life and even
that was really powerful for me to think
like
what version of me is having this
reaction
so i had anxiety about something
one day and to be honest when i get
anxiety i
i'm like pissed i am so tired of this
emotion i am so tired of unnecessary
anxiousness that then i talk myself
around i'm like what
that's such a dumb reason to be worried
and and it just wastes time and it's a
distraction and i hate it
and so i'm like okay how do we let's
let's keep on packing let's keep peeling
back the onion layers because i really
don't want this to be able to affect me
there
were times in my past where anxiety
would shut me down for a day
anxiety now maybe will shut me down for
15 minutes but honestly
i don't even want to lose 15 minutes i i
just like i
don't my my even in a the hardest year
of my life
my i'm still so freaking blessed my kids
are healthy
i'm like i i don't want to waste time in
made up suffering because to me
at least my anxiety is things i'm making
up that have not
even happened so i started to have
anxiety
and then it was the first time that i
was able to sort of use this
like myself at different ages and i
thought
what version of you is having this
reaction right now
and i realized because i you know i know
my trigger and i know what set me off
that i could take it back to
me as a little girl so let's say six
years old and if you grew up in a house
like i did
where you never knew what was gonna set
daddy off
so then you never felt safe well it's
very easy to see how as an adult
i might feel like any kind of thing that
kind of steps outside of what i was
expecting
might be unsafe and so i had this like
beautiful
moment of like oh this is not 37 year
old you
who's freaking out right now this is six
year old you
and so i don't i was gonna say this
sounds woo-woo but i feel like your
audience is like here for it
my therapist said our your subconscious
does not know the difference between
what happened and what you think
happened which is why we can give
ourselves anxiety attacks about the
stuff we're imagining
so she said when you find yourself in
these situations i literally want you to
imagine
that you 37 year old you is talking
to six-year-old you or like what would
you say to calm her down what what she's
like you're a mom like
what would you say to that little girl
and i literally just like imagine this
conversation in my head like oh no
we're safe we're safe here nobody
nobody can hurt us like we are we're
fine like everybody's sick
we're and immediately just all of the
anxious like just drained out of my body
and the power of understanding sort of
which version of you is showing up in
this moment
um i just did an interview with rob bell
do you know rob bell
oh how what right what a weird loop this
is the people yes
i have some friends staying here they're
really really good friends with rob bell
oh how fun they're they're burning time
at the mall right now but um
they know that's so crazy that you just
talked yeah yeah so i
he was just talking about this idea of
um
he said you know people like say like
i'm anxious
and he's like you're not you are not
anxious
you are having an anxious thought or you
are having anxiety
but we start to associate ourself with
the feeling
right we're like i'm pissed no you
as a human you're you are not pissed
you are doing that emotion you might be
having that emotion but that isn't who
you
are and i think when you're experiencing
something
debilitating like anxiety or panic
attack or depression or
something that does feel all-consuming
that we start to
make that like we start to accept that
as who we
are and the ability to separate yourself
from the feeling and at least i'm sure
there's a bunch of different ways to do
it but for me the age thing
helps me to separate myself from that
feeling
like oh no 37 year old you is fully
capable
of handling these things and filling
this up and going through life and being
okay
so it's a different version of you
that's having this moment
which version of you is having this
moment
you would love a conversation with him
yeah yeah that's so funny
philosophical dave and sarah when they
get back and be like so guess who rachel
was talking to just before
me yeah they'll probably send him a
message right away um
it's like the observer i feel like
that's one of the most
being so i moved back home to indiana
with my lived with my parents all summer
because
of heartbreak and um and so
but it was it was actually amazing
and also like i'm not gonna say awful it
wasn't off it was great but i learned a
lot so i was able to
watch this sort of like old dynamic that
i hadn't been so immersed in for so long
i could watch this like codependency
dance happen
and it like i got pulled in initially
like to some of the
some of the old patterns and ways of
reacting and taking things
personally and then i ended up being
like ah that's not uh that didn't feel
good oh why am i why am i getting in the
middle of that
like oh right so then i i i had to learn
i mean i lived there for three months
like i had to learn
how to like remove myself from it so i
became like an observer to this
situation so i could watch this dynamic
happening
and it was like entertaining almost i'm
like and you can just
because you're you're not in it it's
like that's one of the things that's
happened is like the difference between
being
in it and consumed by the emotion and
letting that be
you like rob said the emotion observe
the emotion
and my my therapist said to the other
day she was like
um about judgments but this plays into
the same thing it's like
just narrate just narrate what's going
on
oh that person just cut me off on the
road oh that person is driving their car
oh this that this person was um
busy and they didn't get here instead of
being like ah you know they're late and
whatever and
getting offended or getting hurt just
narrate and observe that's so good
that's really good a really helpful
thing
what um what do you see
like i mean i can look and see like all
kinds of fun dynamics that happened in
my relationship because in relationship
triggers are our teachers and we
can learn the most in our intimate
relationships
um i i've said this a few times like i
could have i wanted to heal and
wanted to learn wanted to unpack all
these things
being in the relationship if we would
have stayed either i think it would have
taken a lot longer
um but it it
has gone really fast being out of it
because you're kind of thrust into it
like what i mean what was it in the
relationship that you can see
like your sort of childhood [ __ ] come up
like what happened what were your
triggers
that were just like you know cause for
me it was like trigger on trigger like
for that was our situation like
our wounds were not compatible like
right that was you know what i mean like
they just kind of right
in each other kept triggering right like
well and i think
yeah what showed up well i
in hearing i there's something
painfully beautiful and i mean i'm sure
he'd be so frustrated that i said
beautiful but you know me and trying to
look for good um
about how we both have completely
different narratives about what has just
happened
and every couple has that
every couple has their version of the
truth
and it is true for them and my truth
is very different than his and what i
have tried to do
is
understand um
try and understand how he could
believe that's true right so you know
when
we first broke up
there were so many um things that he
would say that i would just be like
what are you even talking about like
this is crazy
but then he kept that re it finally like
clicked for you one day
like oh no that is true for him
and if it's true for him then how did i
also contribute to that truth
even though like who i am completely
disagreeing with that being the reality
how i have to also own that that is his
reality
and so how how do i how did i play a
part in that
and i had a lot of anger
for that dynamic and in that process
it allowed me to um
be more empathetic about that being his
truth and i was like okay
i can also understand that if
i grew up in the kind of house that i
grew up in um
i am very non-confrontational so you
would have to
threaten my friends threaten my children
like you'd have to do
something to provoke me to get into
confrontation with you
and most of the time inside of
confrontation
i will shut down and so
he is like the captain of the debate
team
he's an incredi he could have been a
lawyer he would have been incredible at
it
so he like comes alive he's like let me
give you a 17 point process
like here's like all the reasons why i
am right and how i would handle that
is i'm just going to shut down i'm not
going to speak
you win you're right you okay
because i just want to keep the peace
and
there was it was really powerful for me
to understand
if i feel like i have
over communicated over communicated over
communicated and he feels like i haven't
communicated enough and i'm like
that that's crazy but then me
understanding like oh
could there be truth in that if you know
that you tend to shut down if you know
that that's a trigger for you i was
gosh i can't even remember what i was
listening to um
it might even have been a book i was
reading that talked about
are you afraid of their anger
are you afraid of your own anger and i
was like
oh man that is so real
a hundred percent so what was the answer
yes absolutely
afraid of yourself and then i'm like
okay if you're afraid of
their anger and your own anger how
likely are you
to stay in conversation to really unpack
it to dig in deep
probably not very likely and so then
could you give him the benefit of the
doubt that from his perspective
you didn't communicate enough yes
and so to me there's something um
powerful in like we're both right
because we're both it's true to both of
us
because the alternative is and i'm
i'm i know that there are situations
where someone is
um breaking up or getting divorced
from an awful terrible person who did
terrible things and that's not my that's
not my relationship
and so if i know that he is a good man
and he is
there are parts of us that were very
unhealthy
but in this piece then i have to honor
that that is his truth and it is true
to him
i don't know if that made sense yeah
makes sense in my head
no it makes it it's um
it's just sort of accepting it yes
accepting the reality as it is um
what is it that you what is it that
you're
you've learned that you'll you'll you'll
never do again you're like
moving forward next relationship never
doing this this is my
these this or these are my lessons where
i'm like
thank you i can say thank you for these
because i'm
not not not doing this again i don't i
truly don't know how it would have been
possible
for us to have been able to still
have a healthy relationship
given that i am a completely different
person
than the one he married and
one of the most painful hard things
about what was
is that forever there is this tension
between kind of what he signed up for
and who i am today and then there is
this tension
within me to try and keep fitting myself
into a box
that is what would be preferred and so
if it means that for the i'm single for
the rest of my life
that would be preferable to feeling like
who i actually am is not
okay and i think
you know in a totally different scenario
i walked through you know um
with a few friends uh coming out of the
closet and
you know telling people that they were
gay and and having
you know family members disown them and
losing friends and um
you know have walked through some
experiences with people who
when they admitted who they truly were
they lost a lot right they lost
big important pieces of their life
and it i think it's hard to understand
if you haven't
gone through it but losing something
even even really important things
but having the freedom to just be
to just exist as who you are
my best friend wrote a book called worth
it
um and it's about her you know
finding the courage to say that she was
gay and marrying her wife and
um what that process felt like and what
she always tells people is like
i'm not saying it won't be painful it
might be incredibly
painful but it will be worth it
and so i think what i've learned
that i won't repeat again
is show up as anyone other than me
i think you should forgive yourself for
surviving like i think that's what you
like
you will survive at all costs right
i get that feeling yeah yes
even if it means not speaking up
and your anxiety is just your warning
sign right
right well what what would you not what
what are you what will you not do again
um do you have that clarity yet yeah
yeah it's uh
for me it's
not have boundaries i've never had
boundaries
i've learned that from my unpacking
that uh i'm a i'm a fixer
and i just can't fix
anymore and um
so i i just know that i won't i won't
won't
compromise my own values and
boundaries like if someone's not willing
to put the effort in
i'm gonna notice it right right
someone's not you know showing up for me
in the way that makes me feel
you know seen and valued and understood
in a way that's like this is what i
require from a relationship then i'm
gonna see that yep
yep just boundaries that go this is who
i
am if you're not willing to do this
i have to finally i have been this is
this is
what just came through in the last like
and i guess i've kind of known this but
i had two relationships where i wasn't
chosen
and you know i think i saw the pattern
and i think three probably is more
normal for like a pattern but i was like
no no two i ain't doing this damn thing
again
yeah so i was like why like that was my
sadness is like just
you know why wasn't i chosen why wasn't
i you know why wasn't i
why didn't they propose to me why didn't
they want to spend forever and it's
because
i so i wanted that from them but i need
to
i needed to finally choose myself
that's good
i wanted them to choose me but i really
needed to choose myself that was the
lesson
it can be lit there's so many things
that are exact mirror
like exactly reflecting
it's like i've also i made a list the
other day of um
the things i judge in myself and in
others
because there's also a lot to unpack
there like i
judge lazy people people that
um you know don't have you know people
that lack discipline
and all this stuff like i can list these
things that i judge and really it's the
shadow
side of myself that i deny i deny myself
the ability to rest
right myself the ability to just like oh
whatever who cares let go and just relax
like i deny
all those things for myself so the way
you fill in those fragmented cracks of
yourself is you look and you go what do
i judge
and then you go oh my god what is it
something unhealed in me that i'm not
allowing
right what do you judge and well what do
i judge
i i definitely identify there was a i
would say like
when i was talking about earlier when i
was not graceful with myself or not
accepting i would have judged the same
things
i pushed myself so hard i didn't rest i
you know it's like oh you're sick
who cares you got work to do like i all
of the things i
absolutely would have judged other
people for in fact
my best friend did you ever take the
enneagram test did we talk
about this we talked about it but i
haven't i i think a couple of numbers
it's like one through nine or something
one through nine yeah
yeah i think i took it and i thought i
was an eight
you said you're definitely i think you
said i thought you were three but you
or after so the for an eight the number
nine is an option of the number seven so
a seven is an enthusiast like you get
really excited about things you want to
figure them out
and then a nine is a peacekeeper you
want to keep peace between people
so it would have been one of those so
maybe you're not an eight maybe you're
three
but my best friend is a seven which is
the enthusiast
and when we first met probably that
first year i
loved her but i also totally was just
like oh
this woman like you know she's so much
talent why doesn't she write a book like
she does why does she do like
um and i we would go on runs and i'd be
like oh my gosh okay what if she did
this
and then you could do this and then you
could do that
and it for the longest time i was like
why isn't she more
like me right i wasn't putting
those words to it but that was
essentially what was happening
and now i i mean
it is by the grace of god
that this is my best friend because
i this sounds so cheesy but i feel like
in so many ways she taught me how to
live
she taught me how to have margaritas and
drink wine and go on vacation
and just sit and she taught me things
that i
needed so desperately in my life and i
have
such a more beautiful richer
funner existence because
of this person who is not like me at all
and so i there was a time where i would
have judged that and now i'm like
thank you god i know exactly why you put
this person into my path i know exactly
why they're here
and i rub off on her right she did write
the book
um and she rubs off on me and that is
the beauty of
that kind of relationship is like you're
both bringing something to this table
and yeah but i definitely can understand
i would have judged that
long ago for sure um
something that like to sort of
move and shift because i know it's been
heavy and i know we can go into heavy
but i
i right we can also light it up and have
some fun right
the thought that came to mind when you
started to say something earlier was
like
that your new life is gonna cost your
old one
and um obviously that's been happening a
lot for us
so i want you to like paint what's your
new world
what is the new world who's in it what
do you do where do you go
like what jacks you up and gets you
excited like what do you do now that you
never did before
like build the world for me
well i mean i want to build a world
that's like
post coveted because i really miss
i i i don't really like that you want
something travel
right right i really miss travel um
i think the new this is
um dave is so
wonderful but dave is pretty um
and i think he'd say this um he's not
necessarily like
an adventure kind of person like he
doesn't he's pretty good with like
the same doing the same thing and i
really i love i'm a homebody i love
being at home
i love my routine but i love an
adventure
i love doing something i've never done
before i love going to a place like
eating new food meeting a new person
let's make friends let's it is it is
such a big part
of who i am and i think
um we there are there are pieces i don't
know if you've
discovered this but you know this is the
he's the only person i've ever been with
so this is the first time i've ever
broken up with someone so i don't even
all of this is very new to me right
let's
date together let's go on right double
date
i feel like i am not i'm like i can't
even fathom that yet
someday maybe but right now i'm like oh
my god but
um i have never realized how many parts
of myself
i had suppressed just because he didn't
he didn't like doing that thing and i am
positive that that goes both ways like i
am positive there are things
that he loves that he didn't do because
i didn't really like to do them i think
it's
a natural thing when you meet someone
when you're that young because you just
sort of like oh we'll just
become this like blob together instead
of like
our individual selves right and so
there's just a bunch of stuff that i i
i'm excited to explore again
when we're able to do that um
i one of my favorite things ever and i
sort of get to do this through the
podcast but i just i want to be able to
do this in life
is like i want to have this conversation
with no cameras
and wine right i just want to be able to
like meet people
and like no i know but like over like
and this is
all i do i don't have shallow friends
like unless we're talking about the
fabric of the universe and inner child
what are we even doing here yeah what
are we doing here yeah so i think that
the the closer world for me looks like i
want to be able to
have some adventures travel
um i want to be able to create some
stuff that
you know is just having this
conversation with rob about like when
you're known for something
that that's what everybody expects you
to keep being or keep doing or keep
showing up as
and i'm sure you don't know anything
about that right
and what is it you know what does it
look like to be able to
create things um that you create for
yourself
you know in the new book is a very
different tone than i've ever written in
before
and usually it's lots of humor and
they're reverent and self-deprecating
and
i've written this book that's has some
humor but is
hard and is you know it's sad subjects
it's hard things to talk about
and even in that i can sort of see the
audience going like
where's you know girl wash your face too
um and so i think for me
it's about being able to create some
stuff that maybe people aren't used to
seeing from me
so i'm almost done with a script i wrote
a movie
yeah well it could be absolute garbage
but it more
is just that i wanted to try a medium i
hadn't worked in before
i mean which is it's literally never
crossed my mind to write a script so
you're throwing it away like oh it might
be crap like i've never even thought to
do that
well maybe you should i just i i
love um i love a challenge i i feel like
once uh
once i've done something i don't want to
do that same thing again
like i'd rather go and maybe this is
what people see is kind of like
10 more failures before i have another
big success
because at least i was trying different
things as opposed to just like doing the
same stuff over and over
so the the future that i imagine for
myself right now
i can't even fathom a relationship i'm
not that's not even
i don't i'm not even interested
i'm interested in getting to know myself
i'm interested
in um sort of becoming
more me um you know it's funny
when um rumors started to sort of
circulate
and maybe this is normal but i never
experienced this obviously of
like who i was who i was with secretly
or who i was gonna be with and i just
find that so fascinating
that that's what people
think like i'm like i just got out of an
18-year relationship
five months ago you think that
five months is enough time for me to
like
deal with the pain deal with my emotion
come to terms with what has happened
do the therapy you think that five
months
is enough for 18 years
and you think that the solution to my
pain
should be to immediately go get into a
relationship with someone else who also
has
baggage
that's what people do they don't have to
feel so they don't
have to see the [ __ ] so they don't have
to see their [ __ ]
right they do and they don't think and
more than anything it's not even i don't
think it's conscious like
i'm not going to look at that i think
that's 100 sure
um but i think a lot of it is they don't
think anything is
wrong right right like oh just go find
i don't know if you've experienced this
but i've had so many people
like executives and meetings people on
the street like
who will say oh don't worry he's out
there
like you're gonna find and i'm like you
think that's my concern
like you think that's my focus like oh i
gotta go find
the new no no oh my gosh
no like ah the right ones out there oh
you'll find and
you know then there's the whole like
mess in your mind of like i don't think
about anybody else and then okay
like or you're just like oh it feels
icky you're like i'm not there yet
right you know me i'm not there i'm not
there and
i feel like i have even in this hardship
i have i'm so
freaking blessed i have these four
awesome kids
that i have this incredible team of
people that i work with like this is
what i'm doing right now
i started taking horseback riding
lessons
started golfing like i don't know maybe
i'm a golfer
who knows i definitely think you should
come to come to see me in arizona i'm a
member at a really really nice golf
course called scottsdale national bob
parker
who uh started go daddy how's it i'm not
i don't know if i should ask you this
but i want to
is there a world like do people like you
have just
access to race cars
and is there a world that if we were
real-life
friends that you could take me in a car
we could drive very fast because when am
i ever going to get to experience that
is that a thing you know i'm not trying
to manipulate the situation in any way
but i'm just going to sort of like throw
it out there that if
you know we became real live friends yes
um hypothetically hypothetically
speaking if we really were to become
real real friends and we came to see
each other in our respective
states that um that you know i think
there could be a way that i'd i'd find
uh i'd find a race car that that's
probably not very difficult for me and
there's probably a way that i could find
my old helmet and dust it off and
um can you imagine for the youtube video
alone
this would be the funniest thing ever
i gave my family two-seater rides last
year
i had done this i'd done this christmas
package for them
it was a christmas gift for my mom my
dad my sister and her husband
and i called it i called it um
drinking and driving and so it was to
pay for a trip out to napa
to get a two-seater ride with me and go
wine tasting
and so i was already doing a charity
package that had been an auction item
for me to do
two-seater rides so i put them at the
end and um
and i have entertained the idea of
buying uh some a sports car and
i've honestly yeah and be able to give a
good party
every year it feels good like you're
just having a party and you're like all
right who wants
who wants it i'm not encouraging
drinking and driving however it was a
funny way to give a christmas present
um honestly but yeah yeah that could
definitely
that could definitely happen add that to
my adventure
my adventure idea that's just going to
be a byproduct of all of our fruitful
sharing caring growing learning
crying drinking yes and
adventuring i'm here for it i think
that's what life's for i've like
literally started i've even thought to
myself like this whole like
you know you know new boyfriend at some
point i'm like
what like try to like really trying to
identify what's the reason for a
relationship what do i really want from
someone
um and the the top of the list
was adventure and you know what you know
you can
do adventure with anybody and i do tons
of adventures with my girlfriends so
yeah i think we need to go on an
adventure i'm here for it
i'm super here for it as soon as we're
allowed as soon as other countries will
allow us
into them i feel like it's a it's
something that we need to make happen
for sure
i keep checking with my travel agent i'm
like anybody
anybody letting us in yet like no i'll
let you know
all right we're gonna do it
thank you and i'm really i'm really
proud of you and i'm really i think
that it's um i don't think people
understand
uh from the outside looking in
what it's like to deal with you know
breakup and
with uh the whole
energy of it the emotions and the
changes and the dynamics and then
you know the sadness and the anger and
all of that stuff
in a public way and you know there's so
many layers to it there's like
just letting just when people actually
find out which is
usually a little while after it actually
happened because you're kind of like
yeah that's really happen and then
there's sort of like you know moving on
and then there's
it's it's a lot to unpack and then
there's the truth
which is hard because it's personal and
it's private and it's like how much do
you share
and so thank you for sharing thank you
for being honest thank you for
um leading the way leading by example
to how to live and i do think that at 14
while
you can stamp that point in time where
you know your brother died and
everything changed you woke up
and you you you were called to step into
this
life of inspiring people to wake up
to look at themselves to be accountable
and not run away and not do what you
what you said
in in your video a while back where it
said the sexiest thing is to
numb out you're not here for that
yeah thank you yeah i appreciate that
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button